[Applaudissements]
alors on july à tout le monde attend un
bien entendu julien puis avec qui vous
aimeriez passer une nuit
eh bien on d'abord la vie la vie à la
vie c'est la co présentatrice de jeu
canal football club
l'acteur hayden a annoncé marie
portolano bartolone et je voulais pas
qu'on la sait même temps c'est normal
marie portolano pour vous ouais je ne
trouve superbe
d'où une femme très agréable pour la vie
ce serait d'accord pour la nuit or pour
la nuit
gpt chercher très loin j'ai pris ophélie
meunier ah oui zone interdite a interdit
le tournage a lieu juste moi les
pilonneuses interdite
et voilà pour une nuit parce que je
pense que vu les propositions qu'elle
avait vu le niveau de prestation je vais
lui offrir une nuit suffira pour elle ça
sera déjà pas mal
vous êtes magnifique vous pouvez la
séduire ouais si elle est un peu bourré
oui je pourrais je pense que je pense
que quand j ai enfin jamais jamais j'ai
choisi jean-pierre pernaut